all of my best decisions in business and
in life have been made with heart
intuition guts and said look when I'm 80
years old I want to have minimized the
number of regrets that I have you cannot
invent and pioneer if you cannot accept
failure wanna soar get a mentor what's
up believe nation its Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's learn from one of the best
Jeff Bezos and some of his best
life-changing advice mentor me Jeff also
if you want to know what Jeff Bezos and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below the stress primarily
comes from not taking action
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one follow your intuition I believe in
the power of wandering all of my best
decisions in business and in life have
been made with heart intuition guts you
know not not an analysis when you can
make a decision with analysis you should
do so but it turns out in life that your
most important decisions are always made
with instinct intuition taste heart rule
number two
have no regrets how did you go through
making the decision to drop it was a
very good job and take it take this
chance it all seems very obvious now
write this many years later that it paid
off but at the time it was not obvious
no no it was and and and I did do a lot
of soul searching I I went to my boss at
the time and I really liked my job and I
told my boss I was gonna go do this
thing start an internet bookstore and my
wife had already told my wife and she's
like great let's go and I said so I've
also gonna do this he's like this is a
good idea so I think this is a good idea
but it'd be an even better idea for
somebody who didn't already have a good
job and that sort of made some logical
sense to me and he convinced me to think
about it for a couple of days so I went
away I was really trying to get my head
around how to think about this and I
think for me the right way to make that
kind of very personal decision because
those decisions are personal they're not
like data-driven business decisions
there they are you know what does your
heart say and for me it was I could the
best way to think about it was to
project myself forward to age 80 and
said look when I'm 80 years old I want
to have minimized the number of regrets
that I have I don't want to be 80 years
old in a quiet moment of reflection
thinking back over my life
and catalog you a bunch of major regrets
and I think that regrets our biggest
regrets in most cases you can murder
somebody okay you'd regret that but in
most cases our biggest regrets turn out
to the acts of
it's paths not taken and they haunt us
we wonder what would have happened I
loved that person and I never told him
and then they married somebody else I
did you know I didn't do this and so
that's the frame of mind that I put
myself in and I and once I did that once
I thought about that way it was
immediately obvious to me I knew that
when I'm 80 I would never regret trying
this thing that I was super excited
about and failing if it failed fine I
would be very proud of the fact when I'm
80 that I tried and I also knew that it
would always haunt me if I didn't try
and so that would be a regret it would
be a hundred percent chance of a regret
if I didn't try and basically a 0%
chance of regret if I tried and failed
so I think that's a useful metric for
any important life decision rule number
three experiment more you cannot invent
and pioneer if you cannot accept failure
its you to invent you need to experiment
and if it's if you know in advance that
it's going to work it is not an
experiment and so that's a very
important thing you you know it's the
they're inseparable twins failure and
invention is so you have to be willing
to do that
it's embarrassing to fail you know it's
always embarrassing to fail but you have
to say no that's not how this works if I
said to you you have a 10% chance of a
with a particular decision a 10% chance
of a 100x return you should take that
bet every time but you're still going to
be wrong nine out of ten times and it's
gonna feel bad nine out of ten times and
in in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed they
it's very the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation
you know everybody knows that if you
swing for the fences you hit more home
runs but you also strike out more but
with the baseball that analogy doesn't
go far enough because with baseball no
matter how well you connect with the
ball you can only get
four runs the success is capped at four
runs but in business every once in a
while you step up to the plate you hit
the ball so hard you get a thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff and you know one
app one app back and get you a thousand
runs it encourages you to experiment
more it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments rule number four
aim for work life harmony if you're
giving great customer experience there's
the only way to do that is with happy
people you can't do it with a set of
miserable people you know watching the
clock all day so does that include
work/life balance and all those things
yes but I would I use I teach three
leadership classes a year at Amazon I'm
a part of it they're bigger classes but
I come in and teach a session and I
always talk about work-life balance
except I like to use the phrase work
life harmony rather than balance because
to me balance implies a strict trade
whereas I find that when I am happy at
work I come home more energized I'm a
better husband a better dad and when I'm
happy at home I come in and the better
boss and better colleague and so that
that it's not you could be out of work
and we have terrible work-life balance
you know even though you've got all the
time in the world right you could just
feel like oh my god you know I'm
miserable and you would be draining
energy and so you have to find that
harmony it's a much better word and I
think for most people it's about meaning
people want to know that they're doing
something interesting and useful and for
us you know because of the challenges
that we have chosen for ourselves we get
work in the future and it's super fun to
work in the future for the right kind of
person and rule number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip is take
old bets my job one of my jobs as the
leader of Amazon is to encourage people
to be bold and people love to focus on
things that aren't yet working and
that's good it's human nature that kind
of divine discontent can be very helpful
but you really you know it's incredibly
hard to get people to take bold bets and
you need to encourage that and if you're
gonna take bold bets they're gonna be
experiments and if they're experiments
you don't know ahead of time though
they're gonna work experiments are by
their very nature prone to failure but
big success is a few big successes
compensate for dozens and dozens of
things that didn't work so you know bold
bets AWS Kindle Amazon Prime our 3rd
party seller business all of those
things are examples of bold bets that
that did work and they pay for a lot of
experiments I've made billions of
dollars of failures at amazon.com
literally billions of dollars of
failures and you know you might remember
pets calm or Cosmo or you know give
myself a root canal with no anesthesia
very easily none of those things are fun
but but they also they don't matter what
really matters is companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace failure they eventually
get in a desperate position where they
only thing they can do is make a kind of
Hail Mary bet at the very end of their
corporate existence whereas companies
that are you know making bets all along
even you know big bets but not bet the
company bets I don't I don't believe in
bet the company bets that's when you're
desperate that's that's the last thing
you can do
you
now I've got a really special bonus gift
from Jeff on how to choose to do the
hard things that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what bold bet do you need to
take number two what does work life
harmony look like for you and number
three what will you regret if you don't
act on right now
we all have adversity in our lives yeah
III would I would I doubt if you really
you know if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to there's no
lack of adversity and the and by the way
that's good because it's what teaches us
how to get back up you fall down you get
back up it always happens and you know
you get certain gifts in life and you
want to take advantage of those but you
I guess my advice on adversity and
success would be to be proud not of your
gifts but of your hard work and your
choices so you know you may be the kinds
of gifts you get light you know you
might be really good at math it might be
really easy for you that's a kind of
gift but practicing that math and taking
it to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you you can
be grateful for them and thankful for
them and but your choices you choose to
work hard you choose to do hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of
if you want more jeff bezos check out
the top ten rules video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you really enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I first
talked to my my wife who is sitting here
in the audience and she had married a
you know relatively stable